you're in the Marvel Universe you have
play a Marvel character with Claire
temple and then it turns out that cory
booker has it's been revealed is a big
Marvel nerd Marvel Star Trek DC he's
very into it how much does he know does
he really like can he go into the we go
if we go into episodes and like
characters and worlds and favorites and
all of that kind of stuff I turned a
month with a new Star Trek and he was
really really into it right right yeah
it's nice because you know it's getting
to that time of year we get onto all our
cosplay for Halloween I like it all
summer anyway and you know he's he's now
weirded out by that that that's my
favorite thing it's are you gonna go
trick-or-treating together do you think
I don't know but I definitely hope we
get dressed up are you gonna go as Conan
the Barbarian is that you're like outfit
every year here that would be my outfit
no no that we share the first name but
nothing else so if I walked around with
no shirt on and a sword people would say
you need very intimidating no I would
not
people who'd say that guy needs a blood
trail right away no you'd be in a you'd
be in a paddy wagon
minutes open-carry I am Conan I'd try
and lift the sword now wouldn't it
wouldn't go well it